what's up marvel fans we're here with
jacob batalon who plays ned leeds this
is a huge film where do we start with
ned in this one oh my goodness ned is
reeling you know his best friend's
identity just been revealed to the world
so he was just like what does he do next
what are the fos up to now like we're
planning what to do it's crazy does ned
get to get on the action on this one oh
my goodness look you wouldn't believe
ned and mj are killing it
yes so what was it like working with
benedict cumberbatch i mean unbelievable
he's like so professional but also such
a funny amazing human being and everyone
on the cast has been amazing every like
every legend that's been on has been
just amazing so we know ned's arc
throughout these films but what has been
your journey through this i feel like i
mean i've accomplished everything that
i've want to accomplish with ned i feel
like he's definitely become the guy in
the chair to like in the action so i
think in that way he's had a great time
so yeah if you can have any spider-man
gadget in real life what would you
choose uh probably the web wing so i can
fly
that's awesome jacob thank you so much
enjoy the movie thank you
[Music]
you